Dependency injection is
a way to design software so
that code, like a function does not have
its dependencies hard coded into it.
Instead, the information that the
function needs is given to the function
when it's called.
There are a number of reasons for this.
It decreases the coupling between
a function and it's dependencies.
It can decrease the complexity
of that function.
And it makes it easy to configure
the function if it needs a new or
different dependency.
This topic can be a little
convoluted to work through though.
So I've got some friends
to help me explain it.
We've got Brittany.
>> Hi.
>> Cameron.
>> Hello.
>> Kogure.
>> Hi
>> Walter.
>> Hi.
>> And Mike.
>> Hey.
>> Here's what a typical day looks
like in a dependency injection world.
[SOUND].
>> Hey, what's up, Brittany?
>> Hey, Cameron, what's going on?
>> Well, I've got a lot of tires,
any kind, any shape, any size.
>> Great, and where do you sit?
>> Over there.
>> Okay, great, thanks.
>> Cool.
>> Hey.
>> I just got in and I've got that-
>> Okay, what do you got for me?
>> Blue bricks?
>> Okay, of what sizes?
>> One by the ones.
I think there's like a two by two.
There may have been
like a bridge four by-
>> Okay, okay, you have it all.
Got it.
Where do you sit?
>> Over there.
>> Okay, awesome, great.
Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Hi.
>> Reporting for duty.
>> Okay, okay, okay.
What do you have?
How much do you have?
And where do you sit?
>> Red bricks.
A whole bucket full of them.
Over by the wall, third from the left.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
>> Man, another prop for a course.
[NOISE].
No.
Hm.
Hey Brittany.
>> Hey what do you need babe,
because whatever it is, I got it.
>> Yeah, I need a prop for
an upcoming course.
I can do it, but I still need some
red bricks, some blue bricks,
and some tires.
For the blockades I'll need-
>> Okay, okay.
I got it don't worry
I'll be right there.
Okay blue bricks plus red
bricks plus Walter, tires.
Okay.
Quick we need blue bricks.
>> Walter, Walter, Walter,
we need red bricks.
My god [NOISE].
Let's go.
>> You need tires?
>> Yes.
>> All right, let's do it.
>> Let's go, okay.
Okay.
He's got the red bricks.
We got wheels right here.
We got the other bricks right here.
Okay, are we good?
>> Yeah, we're good.
>> Okay, I gotta go back to work.
>> Thanks, Brittany.
[SOUND]
>> So
that was a fun little skit to make.
But dependency injection is an important
architectural software pattern, and
I want to make sure you
understand what's happening.
Instead of being in charge of all
of the bricks and the tires myself,
I just depended on these outside
resources to be provided to me.
Brittany, the injector
in our real life app,
knows where all of the information and
services are.
Whenever an app needs some service or
information it tells
the injector its requirements.
Then the injector fetches
those requirements and
provides them to the calling code.
Then the code uses those
services to accomplish its task.
Dependency injection is
heavily used in Angular.
We'll make use of it ourselves in
the next video on Angular services.
[MUSIC]